ونكمل من التطورات في الداخل الايراني
القضاء الايراني اصدر حكما بالاعدام على
شخص سادس طبعا على خلفيه مشاركته في
الاحتجاجات المستمره منذ حوالي الشهرين
محكمه ثوريه دانه المحتاج بتهم سحب سكين
بقصد القتل بث الرعب خلق حال من انعدام
الامن في المجتمع هذه الاحكام تاتي في
الوقت الذي يواصل فيه المحتجونه
احتجاجاتهم الليليه في عشرات المدن
الايرانيه طبعا تضامنا مع مدينتي مهاباد
الكرديه التي اشارت تقارير الى ارتكاب
القوات الامنيه الايرانيه حملات قمع غير
مسبوقه فيها
الريال
[موسيقى]
ضد المحتاجين ومن يدعمه الامن الايرانيه
ممثلتين على خلفيه خلعه هما الحجاب طبعا
للاحتجاجات الاعلام الرسمي الايراني
محاوله السلطات اخماد هذه الاحتجاجات بحسب
اعلام ايراني رسمي فان القضاء الايراني
مع سبع شخصيات معروفه سينمائيه وسياسيه
والرياضيه بسبب نشر المحتوى وصفه الق
بالستفزازي دعما لحركه الاحتجاج هذه الصور
وهذا الفيديو الذي خرجت فيه الممثله خرجت
بدون حجاب ربطت شعرها كمل شاهدنا في هذه
الصوره وهي اشاره دائما ما تستخدمها
النساء قبل الاتجاه الى المشاركه في
التظاهرات كما نشاهد في هذه الصوره
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا هذا بالنسبه للاعتقالات اما
فيما يتعلق بالتحركات الامنيه على الارض
فقط قام الحرس الثوري الايراني بتعزيز قوه
البريه في محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه شمال
غربي البلاد لماذا هناك هناك تقع العديد
من المدن الكرديه خاصه مها باد التي تشهد
كما ذكرنا سابقا مظاهره شعبيه واسعه
القوات البريه التابعه للحرس الثوري في
محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه زعمه ان
التعزيزات تاتي لمواجهه ما وصفته
بالتحركات الانفصاليه في اشاره طبعا الى
الاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه المراعضه وقد
توعد الحرس الثوري المحتاجين بما وصفها
باجراءات حاسمه لردعهم وفي المقابل اعرب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقه من تصاعد
العنف ضد المتظاهرين في ايران خاصه في تلك
المدينه مدينه مهاباد قال ان واشنطن تسعى
الى محاسبه المسؤولين عن العنف وتواصل دعم
الشعب الايراني